china fires a hypersonic low orbit
missile capable of striking the united
states secretary of transportation pete
boudijedge returns to inform us how
useless he is and superman isn't about
the american way anymore i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the men's shapiro show is sponsored by
express vpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben first let us remind you before we
get to the news you're spending too much
on your cell phone bill so why don't you
just switch over how many times i have
to tell you switch over to pure talk usa
because you're spending too much money
with verizon or at t or t-mobile now i
know what you are thinking which is that
these big companies they have sort of an
oligopoly on good coverage but that is
untrue because pure talk usa uses the
same 5g network as one of the big guys
but they're going to charge you about
half the price the average family is
saving over 800 a year by making that
switch that's because the big providers
they're also charging you for all their
overhead and their big advertising
campaigns and all the rest of those
stores you never go to instead switch on
over to puretalk usa you can keep your
number keep your phone or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids get a limited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and listen if you still want unlimited
data you can still get it and save a
fortune go to puretalk.com shop for the
plan that is right for you they have a
30-day risk-free guarantee so you
literally have nothing to lose head on
over to puretalk.com enter promo code
shapiro you will save 50
off your very first month of coverage
that's puretalk.com promo code shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wireless go
check them out right now alrighty so
i'm going to begin with two contrasting
stories because this really does sum up
the state of where america is right now
culturally so
two stories break over the weekend
seemingly unrelated but kind of related
okay one is this amazing story about how
china had developed this massive missile
technology that basically took the
united states by surprise a lot of
people are calling it a second sputnik
moment sputnik of course is the moment
when the soviet union was the first to
launch a spacecraft that actually
orbited the earth and the rest of the
and the rest of the world's like whoa
where did the ussr come from here we
thought that they were way behind
technologically speaking this of course
launches the space race and leads to
president kennedy suggesting that
eventually we're going to go to the moon
right all of this was about the soviet
union surprising everyone with the
technological prowess of sending a
spacecraft into earth orbit okay well
now the chinese have basically done the
same thing and this is going to lead you
would imagine to a bit of a new arms
race here according to the uk daily mail
beijing has mocked america by saying
their secret test of a 21 000 mile per
hour nuclear-capable missile which
orbited the globe before returning to
earth to strike its target is a new blow
to the us mentality of strategic
superiority over china the job follows a
report from the financial times which
cited five unnamed intelligence sources
saying that the chinese military
launched the long march rocket in august
carrying a hypersonic glide vehicle into
low orbit
it circled the globe before descending
toward its target which it missed by
about two dozen miles in a technological
development that would overcome us
anti-ballistic missile systems so right
now the united states has anti-ballistic
missile systems that are largely based
in alaska because the idea is that if
the russia that if the chinese were to
fire a missile capable of striking the
united states you would have to travel
over the north part of the globe and
then we would see it and then we would
be able to use our anti-missile
technology and shoot it down from alaska
but the new technology allows the
chinese to strike the united states from
the south by sending a missile into low
orbit the incident caught the us
intelligence community by surprise it
shows china has made astonishing
progress on the development of its
hypersonic weapons according to sources
one person familiar with the test said
we have no idea how they did this to rub
salt into their wounds an op-ed in the
chinese state media global times
beijing's mouthpiece said the test means
that there's a new key member in china's
nuclear deterrence system adding this is
a new blow to the uss mentality of
strategic superiority over china so this
is explicitly an attempt to defeat the
united states missile defense system
again those hypersonic missiles can
reach speeds up to 21 000 miles per hour
they can strike anywhere on earth from
space within minutes and the goal here
is to avoid the normal trajectories
for the ballistic missiles and thus
evade u.s missile defense
so all of this is to say that china is
obviously upping the ante here china has
been becoming more and more belligerent
on the world stage they're taking
advantage of american weakness and
meanwhile what's happening here in the
united states what's happening here in
the united states is that many americans
and i would say a large percentage of
people in the democratic party are
simply embarrassed by the idea of a
muscular america period
and this has now become a cultural thing
because not only are there a lot of
americans who are embarrassed by the
idea of a muscular america at home right
we should all be embarrassed of being
americans america was founded in 1619
america really has nothing to show the
rest of the world also at the same time
the united states should be catering to
for example the chinese market you can
see both of those moves happening in
this what would be a kind of small
cultural story normally except it really
isn't when you're talking about iconic
american art and the transformation of
that american art into a sort of
anti-american art that
there's there's a reason for that and
it's a big problem
so the story that emerged over the
weekend is that superman is officially
moving on from the american way so the
slogan for superman so we've had a lot
about superman in the past several weeks
turns out that the new superman who is
superman's son is is bisexual which is
all very exciting and we have to have uh
superman of of every sexual orientation
before america truly has reached it's
it's apex as i've suggested until
superman is actually a transgender
little person
i i think this is all pink washing but
superman himself right the classic
original character is going to be
getting rid of the slogan that was used
for many years for superman truth
justice in the american way now superman
as a character had been moving in this
direction for quite a while
so you'll recall then superman returns
there was a line where it was used as a
throwaway it was truth justice and all
the rest of that stuff right it's very
cynical movie and the idea was that that
there's nothing special about the
american way and truth be told if you go
back internationally to the superman
character
superman had used a variety of different
slogans over the years but the one that
everybody identified with superman was
truth justice in the american way
because that was coined during the 50s
and then it was used again in the in the
christopher reeves movie of the same
title superman in which he says truth
justice and the american way and well
now they're getting rid of it officially
jim lee the chief creative officer and
publisher of dc announced on saturday
during the virtual fan event dc fandom
that the man of steel's motto will be
evolving from the well-known mantra that
he fights for truth justice in the
american way superman's new mission
statement is truth justice and a better
tomorrow which of course suggests that
the american way is not all that great
we need quote unquote a better tomorrow
which sounds frankly like every other
revolutionary movement that has ever
taken place on planet earth truth
justice in a better tomorrow and it'd be
indistinguishable from
a chinese superman what exactly would
chinese superman say presumably truth
justice and a better tomorrow in a press
statement the company said the decision
is meant to quote better reflect the
storylines we are telling across dc and
to honor superman's incredible legacy of
over 80 years of building a better world
so as i say the the fact is that truth
justice and the american way didn't
start with the first superman books it
was starting to it was used during the
adventures of superman tv series in the
1950s but there's no question that it
was the slogan that was most associated
with superman over the life of the
character
and now of course yeah the new superman
is not just bisexual he also marches in
favor of climate change regulation and
all the rest okay so why is this
important what's the juxtaposition to
china firing hypersonic missiles the
idea is that there is nature abhors a
vacuum and so does international
politics
when great empires like the united
states in the united states is a great
world empire it may not be a territorial
holding world empire in the same way as
the british empire but it is the global
hegemon when a global hegemon decides
that it is no longer interested in
global leadership when it starts naval
gazing and seeing that it is actually
the problem and that we have to change
our own ways that we you know we need to
bring everybody home we need to we need
to forget about our role in the world we
need to forget about our own ideals and
and how they stack up against other
ideals
because after all the united states has
its own problems when hegemon start to
do this
other countries take advantage of this
other countries are going to step into
the breach a hesitant
united states a united states that
believes that it is not inherently good
that there's no such thing as quote
unquote the american way when your
entire culture has decided that the
american way is really more akin to
racism bigotry homophobia inequality
and when you stack up the united states
not against the other countries of the
world in terms of what the united states
does and has done but in terms of some
sort of utopian ideal
you're always going to fall short but
i'll tell you what china is not having
any of those same sorts of issues right
china right now is doing two things
right they are muscular on foreign
policy and they are hyper-jingoistic at
home so china infamously last week
decided they were going to take down the
last monument to the victims of
tiananmen square in hong kong and the
rest of the world kind of shrugged
and the rest of the world kind of shrug
because china is doing what countries
have historically done when they want to
prove themselves muscular on the world
stage they're saying to their own
citizens that our way of life is better
and we are stronger and meanwhile the
entire west is in the middle of
the throes of chaos and confusion
ideologically and philosophically this
this sort of internally driven
is what's wrong with us why are we so
bad we're the problem
and the only way to correct that problem
is of course to bring home all of our
resources and then spend it on ourselves
until we die because the the best way of
fixing the problems internal to the
united states is basically to get fat
and lazy and climb into that warm
bathtub and cut open your veins like
pantangially and godfather ii
like the roman emperors of old
declining dying empires act like the
united states is acting right now
empires that are on their eyes act like
china another part of this that's so
astonishing in terms of the attitude is
that china is uniquely vulnerable right
now
so combined with china's new jingoism is
an economic singlism that's really bad
for their economy because here's the
thing karl marx talked about the
inherent contradictions of capitalism
and how this was inevitably going to
bring about the downfall of capitalism
okay the reality is that capitalism is
extraordinarily robust and capitalism
can't be brought down by capitalism
capitalism can only be brought down by
people who wish to overthrow capitalism
that's not true with regard to communism
which relies on suppression communism
relies
on destroying people who stand in its
way and the inherent contradictions of
communism are
replete in china
right now china is experiencing some
pretty significant economic issues now
would be an excellent time to take
advantage of chinese economic weakness
because of course if china's making the
case for quote-unquote the chinese way
they also have to be making the case for
the chinese communist system which is
actually a particularly unsuccessful
system
in terms of economics the only part of
the chinese system that works at all
is the part of the chinese system that
is capitalism and free trade dependent
the part of the system that is rooted in
redistribution and government subsidies
is wildly unsuccessful on a dollar to
dollar level like they'll develop a
piece of technology once in a while but
on a competing and free market stage
china can't compete which is and
meanwhile you have the leadership in
china that's turning inward xi jinping
is basically saying china ought to rule
the world and our economic system has to
get more communists not less communist
those two things are in extraordinary
contradiction
because the more china becomes more
communistic at home the weaker they are
according to the wall street journal
with its pandemic recovery in the rear
view mirror china now faces a prolonged
period of slower growth with increasing
policy uncertainties as beijing attempts
to carry out ambitious long-term reforms
china's economy recorded a steeper than
expected economic slowdown in the third
quarter of the year expanding 4.9 from a
year earlier the disappointing growth
rate reflected a host of headwinds
tighter rules on the property market
that have chilled activity in the
private sector widespread power
shortages continued concerns about kovac
19.
while economists had predicted momentum
to slow from the first and second
quarters of the year as the statistical
base effect from last year faded
the chinese economy now faces a more
daunting set of challenges than had been
foreseen earlier in the year
after china emerged from a coronavirus
react to 2020 as the only major world
economy to report gross domestic product
growth it's at a targeted march for
expansion of six percent or more for the
year
at the same time beijing made it clear
it wanted to use the extra breathing
room to take on long festering issues in
the economy including reigning in
household and corporate debt
particularly in the country's frothy
housing market as well as pursuing
ambitious climate goals and more tightly
regulating technology sector practices
that have been seen as widening
inequality so china decided to double
down
on the communism and maoism of its
economic program as opposed to doing
what a lot of people thought they would
do which is sort of a continuing embrace
of the gradual reopening here of the
chinese economy and so china is actually
very vulnerable right now or they would
be vulnerable to a civilization that
actually cared about its future and had
the strength of its convictions but we
are not that civilization i'll get to a
story that demonstrates this in just one
second the culture war in the united
states matters an awful lot and it
matters an awful lot because it does
have impact for things like foreign
policy it has impact as to whether you
believe the united states ought to face
up to the challenges of china or whether
the united states can even say with any
level of certainty that it is better
than china that the west is better than
china and ought to win on a
civilizational scale
i do not think that it is a coincidence
that the china that is pouring money
into its military the china that is
pouring money and resources into the
possibility of retaking taiwan and
building belton road and sucking its
citizens dry to do all of these things i
don't think that it's any coincidence
that that country is also pursuing more
communism at home because again they're
trying to demonstrate the superiority of
their own value system meanwhile the
west is hell-bent on demonstrating the
inferiority of its own value system
on self-flagellating in pathetic fashion
that's not how you win a war
a war of ideas or a traditional war
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about a simple
fact right now there are over 10 million
open jobs in the united states and there
are not enough workers to make up for
those jobs so let's say that you're an
employer and you're looking for a great
employee how do you even find those
people the job market is really
difficult right now for employers the
best way is you head on over to zip
recruiter
ziprecruiter has a feature it's called
invite to apply it gives you the hiring
manager the power to pick your favorites
from top candidates right now you can
try that for free at zip recruiter.com
dailywire how does invite to apply work
well
when you post a job on zip recruiter
they send you the most qualified people
for your job then you can easily review
the candidates and invite your top
choices to apply for your job lauren
webb svp of talent acquisition foreman
doula health raves about zip recruiters
invite to apply she says i love that
feature because we have a much higher
follow-through rate if i invite
candidates it's easy for me it's easy
for them in fact according to zip
recruiter internal data jobs where
employers use zip recruiters invite to
apply get on average two and a half
times more candidates which helps make
for a faster hiring process see for
yourself just head on over to this
exclusive web address ziprecruit.com
dailywire to try zip recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zipper crew is indeed
the smartest way to hire it's a perfect
encapsulation of the culture war that is
taking place between china and the
united states is the story from the new
york times
it's about a professor from the
university of michigan who has now found
himself in the crosshairs quote it was
supposed to be an opportunity for music
students at the university of michigan
to learn about the process of adapting a
classic literary text into an opera from
one of the music school's most
celebrated professors the composer
bright chang
but at the first class meeting of this
fall's undergraduate composition seminar
when professor shang hit play on the
1965 film of shakespeare's othello
starring lawrence olivier it quickly
became a lesson in something else
entirely
students said they sat in stunned
silence as olivier appeared on screen
and thickly painted blackface makeup
even before class ended 90 minutes later
group chat messages were flying along
with at least one email of complaint to
the department reporting that many
students were quote incredibly offended
both by this video and by the lack of
explanation as to why this was selected
for our class
within hours shang had sent a terse
email issuing the first of what would be
two apologies then after weeks of emails
open letters and cancelled classes it
was announced on october 1st that
professor shang a two-time pulitzer
finalist and winner of a macarthur
genius grant was voluntarily stepping
back from the class entirely in order to
allow for a positive learning
environment
the incident might have remained just
the latest flashpoint at a music program
that has been roiled in recent years by
a series of charges of misconduct by
star professors but a day before shang
stepped down a long scathing medium post
by a student in the class rippled across
twitter before getting picked up in
newsweek fox news the daily mail and
beyond entangling one of the nation's
leading music schools in the
supercharged national debate over race
academic freedom and free speech
to some observers it's a case of campus
cancel culture run amok with overzealous
students refusing to accept an apology
with the added twist and here's
the story that the chinese-born
professor sheng was a survivor of the
cultural revolution during which the red
guards had seized the family piano
okay so
the reason that he was showing the
lawrence olivier othello as sort of a
shakespeare maven there are many film
versions of othello
and they range from orson welles doing
what fellow like in blackface to
lawrence olivier doing othello
to lawrence fishburne obviously doing
othello he's a black man
and there's
many versions of othello okay the
lawrence olivier version is a classic
version of the film
he's not wearing blackface because he's
seeking to mock black people he's
wearing blackface in that film because
he is playing othello who is a black
character this is how othello was played
on the stage for literally centuries
it is not insensitive for the professor
to show you a classic film even though
we wouldn't do this today we wouldn't
make that film the same way today we'd
cast a black actress othello for sure it
is not offensive to show a 1965 film
starring the greatest actor maybe ever
playing othello
in the way that othello was
traditionally played on the stage
and that that is really not any reason
to cancel anybody but again what makes
the story incredible is that this guy
fled china and he fled the cultural
revolution right the cultural revolution
in china was all about telling people
they could not think in a particular way
and now he fled to the united states
becomes this very famous music professor
and then
is basically forced out of his class
because he violated some unwritten
precept of stupidity
as a teenager during the cultural
revolution to avoid being sent to a farm
to be re-educated he auditioned for an
officially sanctioned focal music
ensemble and was sent to king high
province a remote area near the tibetan
border according to a university
biography
after the universities reopened in 1976
he got a degree in composition from
shanghai university in 1982 he moved to
the united states and earned eventually
a doctorate at columbia university
so the the kind of ridiculousness of the
of of cancelling
a survivor of the cultural revolution in
precisely the same way that students
shouted down professors and demanded
their expulsion during the chinese
cultural revolution
the the irony of that
and the and the depth of the depravity
of that can't be overstated to take a
survivor of the cultural revolution and
then subject him to very similar sort of
activity in the united states
is is pretty incredible and demonstrates
the weakness that lies at the heart of
the western project at this moment
liberalism traditional classical
liberalism does rely on an acceptance of
certain natural law values and when
those are undermined the liberalism
tends to turn in on itself and collapse
in on itself
the doubt and the sort of value
pluralism that liberalism accepts
isaiah berlin famous philosopher he
suggested that the value of liberty lay
in what he called value pluralism
meaning we all have different values and
we sort of have to leave each other
alone and that's why we need liberty but
that requires you have certain baseline
level of values as a society about which
you are actually quite confident
value pluralism collapses into moral
relativism into all value systems are
equal unless you believe that there is
in fact a higher value system now as
isaiah berlin thought it can be kind of
a broad value system things like free
speech are good things like you have to
have property rights like those can
be the higher values and then within
those kind of broad frameworks you can
have a lot of disagreement about how to
balance things like safety social safety
nets and property rights right you can
you can have those conversations but you
have to have that broad framework and
you have to be proud and muscular about
that broad framework when you are not
however then you tend to collapse it
very quickly into the sort of
self-destructive thought that has taken
place on america's campuses and now
spread out like a cancer across american
society culminating
in our cultural icons being destroyed
culminating in a government that is
afraid to stand up for any sort of
american values in any serious way
against the radicals inside its own
midst
and and you turn a civilization that
once was the sort of light of the world
and western civilization was the light
of the world and it continues to be the
light of the world if it has any sort of
understanding of what the rest of the
world looks like
instead it seems like we are spending
all of our time worried about how we
cleanse ourselves and purge ourselves of
all of our sins or all of our supposed
sins and adopt the methods of the
cultural revolution in order to do so
meanwhile the actual cultural
revolutionaries on the other side of the
world have no such qualms about imposing
their own values on their own people and
then spreading those values outward
you can hollow out an empire pretty
easily this way and that's exactly what
is happening but at least we are at
least we're telling ourselves that we're
fat and happy
i mean how do you keep there there are a
few ways that you keep a population of a
civilization in check now you can do it
through oppression is the way the
chinese do it through open repression
where you just tell people to sit down
and shut up and you'll shoot them if
they don't listen
you can also do it through a certain
level of patriotism
right which can shade over on the
negative side into jingleism but is a
very important thing right nationalistic
belief belief that your nation is great
does keep people motivated it can be
used for good it can be used for ill
but as i say it can be used for good
or you can basically bribe people you
can bribe people and keep them
complacent as the civilization falls
into decline and that seems to be the
path that the united states wants to
take or release the democratic party is
now pushing and we should all sort of be
happy with the kind of crappy mediocrity
into which we are sinking because after
all the government is capable of paying
for everything or borrowing for
everything and in the long run as john
maynard keynes said we are all dead
anyway we'll get some more of this in
just one second first let's talk about a
simple fact if you're going to refile
your house like now is the time to
refill your house because the fact is
that the interest rates likely are going
to rise in the somewhat near future
because
frankly the federal government can't
afford to keep pushing out zero interest
rates right now is a great time to make
a positive impact on your budget before
your end mortgage rates remain at near
money-saving lows
now you might be thinking your mortgage
is already fine as it is well i mean why
not check it out why not find out
whether that is true the answer can be
found in american financing america's
home for home loans they give sound
advice they don't pressure you instead
their salary based mortgage consultants
get to know you so they can lead you to
greater overall savings it could be a
shorter loan term or consolidating debt
because there's more to a refund than
just a lower rate and it's the reason
why they save customers up to a thousand
bucks a month so why not see what
american financing can do for you make
the 10 minute call right now before
those rates are gone 866 721 3300 that's
or visit 866-721-3300
that's americanfinancing.net nmls 182
334 nmls consumeraccess.org go check
them out
americanfinancing.net 866 721
3300. okay so as i say
the way that you keep a population
complacent while the civilization begins
to sink into irrelevance and endanger
its future is you just keep them fat and
happy you keep them on the dole now the
problem is that the pro that the issues
with that are already beginning to sink
in i think that a fundamental sea change
happened over the course of this
pandemic there are many fundamental sea
changes
it turns out that it doesn't take people
long to acclimate to new circumstances
right you can put people viktor frankl
wrote about this in much worse
circumstances with regard obviously to
the holocaust viktor frankl talked about
the fact that people who sort of had a
baseline level of of
happiness tended to actually continue
that attitude even under the worst
circumstances human beings are
incredibly adaptable creatures right
this is why human beings are such a
successful species despite the fact that
we're essentially hairless apes who are
very vulnerable have no claws and are
less physically strong than any of the
predators who surround us we're very
smart we're very adaptable okay that
adaptability is great when you're
talking about how do human beings adapt
to difficult circumstances it's very
useful but how do human beings adapt to
being innervated how do human beings
adapt to being told that they need to
stay in their homes for a full year and
a half and that they can't come outside
except to protest for quote-unquote
social justice and that the government
is going to just give the money how do
human beings adapt to that well the
answer is they adapt to a new normal
really really quickly i mean i think
this is what lies behind a lot of the
passion for cloth masking which again is
not effective against delta according to
dr michael osterholm
of the former biden administration
like the cloth mask against delta are
very questionable
can 95's different story but that's not
the point the point is that a lot of
people have gotten very used very
quickly the sort of lifestyle the
pandemic has launched for them working
from home being paid by the government
to stay home unemployment benefits all
this kind of stuff and so people have
adapted to this and the democrats know
this
now the problem is that the system not
only is not built for this but the
system can't survive this
you cannot have a a capitalistic
minority who are providing for the
socialistic majority
if your goal is you're going to sit home
and the government is going to pay for
everything and the workforce
the the work
of the the uh workforce participation
rate
is 60
and dropping that's gonna be a major
problem and it's not just a problem for
the united states by the way
there's an article today in the wall
street journal about how the workforce
participation rates are dropping all the
way across the west
right the the workforce participation
rate problem is not a uniquely united
states problem all across the world
because people were paid to stay home
they're just staying home right now and
this is coming along with
a lot of serious economic problems
including inflation when you have fewer
people producing fewer things but the
government is giving them a lot of money
they spend the money following the goods
as much as more as milton friedman
famously suggested inflation is anywhere
and everywhere a monetary problem
right
meaning that too much money following
too few goods
it's a monetary phenomenon okay so when
economists say that the problems are
going to continue into next year they're
going to continue a lot longer than that
unless people get back to work
okay and again this is the tacit bargain
that your leadership is making with you
the tacit bargain is we will give you
everything that you could possibly want
we can protect you from every
vicissitude of life all you have to do
is just recognize that you're living in
the last days of the civilization
and these two things are combined now
what they lie about is they say okay
well now that we once we correct all
those problems once we've built back
better in the words of the bible
administration once we've done all of
that and built back better then maybe we
can be muscular on the world stage again
but they have no intention of doing that
it is not a coincidence that the same
people who are perfectly sanguine about
getting rid of truth justice in the
american way are the exact same people
who want to bribe you to stay home
okay that is not a like that is a 100
crossover venn diagram the venn diagram
there is a circle it is a concentric
circle
the people who are are fine
and with getting rid of american
branding and believing that america is
kind of a nefarious force on the world
stage there is a 100 crossover with
people who believe that the government
should pay you to stay home that is not
because they want to make america
stronger it's because they believe that
america in its essence is wrong and
needs to fundamentally change
and once it fundamentally changes that
will require america to remain
pacifistic and surrender oriented on the
world stage not the opposite it's not
that we're going to get redistributed at
home and fix all of our problems and
then we'll get muscular no
we're not we're never getting muscular
on the world stage
okay so that means that the problems are
going to continue to attend according to
the wall street journal uncomfortably
high inflation will grip the united
states economy well into 2022 as
constrained supply chains keep upward
pressure on prices and increasingly curb
output according to economists surveyed
this month by the wall street journal
economists on average see inflation at
5.25 in december just slightly less than
the rate that has prevailed since june
assuming a symbol similar level in
october november that would mark the
longest inflation has been above five
percent since early 1991. michael moran
chief economist at dawa capital markets
america says it's a perfect storm supply
chain bottlenecks tight labor markets
ultra easy monetary and fiscal policies
emphasis on the last part
okay because the ultra easy monetary and
fiscal policies are incentivizing a
tight labor market they're telling
people stay home if you are going to
come back ask for an inflated wage but
this drives up the inflated prices
as much as the biden administration
wants to talk about the great good of
people staying home and driving up wages
wages have been outplayed outpaced by
inflation this year that does not mean a
rising real wage means a dropping real
wage
according to these respondents average
estimates consumer price inflation will
drop to 3.4 by the end of june next year
then 2.6
by the end of 2022 that's still above
the average 1.8 percent that prevailed
in the decade before the pandemic
economists also have slashed their
growth forecast this year to an average
3.1 percent annualized in the third
quarter that is below half of what they
were surveyed as thinking it was going
to be in july
they thought we were going to get seven
percent quarterly growth
annualized in july they're down to 3.1
also they are lowering their projected
fourth quarter growth to 4.8 percent
from 5.4 percent
michael brown principal u.s economist
visa says quote consumer spending and by
extension gdp growth is being limited by
high rates of inflation eroding the real
purchasing power of consumers
so democrats are trying to blame this
all on the supply chain issues but it's
not just the supply chain issues it's
when you pay people to stay home when
you incentivize people to stay home and
when you treat them for a year and a
half as wards of the state it's very
difficult to get wards of the state to
start being independent human beings
again people become risk-averse people
become afraid
it's sort of like the problem that you
have at places like sea world where you
take a wild animal you put in a
domesticated situation
and then you feed it fish every single
day you can't just release it back in
the wild because it won't know what to
do
this is what we've done with huge swaths
of the american population we've made
them dependent on the federal government
to the point that people don't know how
to undergo risk anymore we may have
reached the end of risk the end of risk
sounds really nice except that real
world risk still exists you're just
shielded from it you're shielded from it
by the decline of the united states
if the united states absorbs all the
risk then in the end there won't be any
innovation and there won't be any growth
dhl executive jim munmeier was on
national tv over the weekend he says
these supply chain issues are going to
continue all the way through 2022. if
there's a truck available to get cargo
off the docks of the port it could come
to a warehouse like this how long the
goods wait for the next truck is another
potential delay i think domestically
because the truck driving shortage is
such an issue we're going to see issues
all the way through 2022. okay meanwhile
people are judging this really does sum
up the entire problem so pete booty
judge is the supposedly brilliant
secretary of transportation we know he's
brilliant because he taught himself
norwegian in order to read a book or
something i mean sure he was kind of a
mediocre mayor of south bend indiana who
couldn't even fill the potholes and then
was made the secretary of transportation
for diversity purposes
but
this this brilliant human being who was
going to fix all of our problems right
he was one of the great administrators
who's gonna fix our problems he went
completely awol for two months right
completely awol and nobody bothered to
ask where he was
he was on paid paternity leave
now i'm not going to get into the debate
over whether men should take paternity
leave
i don't have a general problem with men
taking a certain amount of paternity
leave although i think two months is is
too long a time and i'll tell you on a
personal level
you know my thank god we have a family
structure my my in-laws came down my mom
was available when we had all three of
our babies my paternity lasted maybe a
day and a half
like i'd come home early i'd try to
clear my schedule as much as i could to
help out my wife and i will say that i
think the factors are very different for
paternity leave when you are taking care
of a woman who is recovering from an
actual physical trauma which is what
birth is as opposed to when you just
have a surrogate bird the babies like
the factors are just different
that's not to say that if people judge
isn't contributing at home that's fine
i don't want to pay for it
and not for two months you don't pay for
it for two weeks
i get it
but for two months it's kind of a long
time in the middle of a supply chain
crisis anyway
people who judge goes absolutely awol
for two weeks and then he comes back
long enough to do state of the union
which is really what our government
officials right now they just they're
for the innovation and they themselves
are kind of lazy i mean they themselves
don't really do anything
they're administrators who spend every
day writing rules for you and they're
not paying attention to any of the rules
for themselves and then drawing a
government paycheck while keeping their
eye on the prize i mean the reason that
people judge the secretary of
transportation is because he wants to
run for president
he couldn't win a senate slot in india
he couldn't win a gubernatorial slot in
indiana so he ran for president as a
mayor of a small town
and then thanks to his diversity
quotient he was elevated into the
cabinet with no qualifications for this
position other than he likes choo choo
trains
i mean he literally said that he
literally in his opening speech he was
like i love trains trains are great
trains are yeah great i'm glad that you
once read murder on the orient express
dude not sure why that qualifies you to
help run the nation's supply chain
anyway p booty judge as well was
admitting over the weekend that there
are going to be supply chain problems
into next year
well certainly a lot of the challenges
that we've been experiencing this year
will continue into next year but there
are both short-term and long-term steps
that we can take to do something about
it
okay um so
that's not great the good news is that
booty judge was on national tv defending
having left his job for two months and
nobody noticing as i said last week if
you leave your job for two months and no
one even bothers to ask where you are
that means your job is completely
superfluous and we should eliminate your
entire department
hey i don't even understand how that
works if i went absent from this show
for a day i get emails from people who
are like where's the show
if my producers just took off for two
months at a time they would no longer
work here because that's not a real
possibility you can't do that at the
very least you gotta delegate it to your
to your deputy okay but here is pete
booty judge saying paid family so now
he's going to tell us how hard he is
working
as a father with his
co-father husband taking care of babies
like again not to demean family work
because you know working at home is a
thing and being with your kids is
definitely a lot of work it just came
off a weekend of being with my kids it's
a lot but you're being paid to be
secretary of transportation i don't
think anybody the debate here is not
over whether men should spend more time
with their kids the debate here is
whether the federal government should
pay men to spend more time with their
kids while completely abdicating their
jobs in the middle of an inflationary
shipping crisis here is pete booty judge
defending staying home and feeding the
babies while completely abdicating his
job
paid family leave is important it's
important as a matter of family values
it's important to our economy and one
more thing that i think is
maybe underappreciated
when somebody welcomes a new child into
their family and goes on leave to take
care of that child that's not a vacation
it's work it's joyful wonderful
fulfilling work but it is work and it's
time that our nation join pretty much
every other country in the world and
recognize that so i noticed that you're
getting benefits and living off those
benefits people judge that i pay for so
that's exciting stuff by the way most
major american companies do have some
sort of paternity or maternity leave so
it's not like people judge is preaching
to anybody here he's just growing a
third arm to pat himself on the back
right here he just has no good answer as
to why he just took off for two months
so he was asked specifically by jake
tapper so why didn't you just appoint an
acting secretary like you were just gone
so the answer here by the way is the
entire biden administration should go on
paternity leave like all of you just go
away the country would be better off if
you just left because all you're doing
is sitting around and spending all of
our money while patting ourselves on the
back for being lazy bums here's pete
booty judge
why didn't you
or the department of transportation make
an official announcement when you went
on parental leave and why did you not
appoint an acting secretary while you
were away
well so the way this works is there is a
deputy secretary polly trottenberg who's
doing phenomenal work and who as deputy
secretaries do can fill in when a
secretary is not available now look even
though i've been on paternity leave and
i'm proud of it obviously given the
nature of my job
when you take a job like mine you
understand and accept that you're going
to have to be available
24 7 depending on what's going on and
you're going to have to engage and i did
okay he didn't literally no one knew he
was gone for two months no one knew he
was gone
like that was not a thing and then he he
tells the final lie again and this is
the one that really matters which is
that
we can innervate you into complete
compliance right
you shouldn't worry about any of the
economic problems you're seeing you
shouldn't worry about the inflation you
shouldn't worry about the fact nobody's
going back to work it's actually good
all of this is good
right sure china's firing hypersonic
low-orbit missiles to test against the
united states
and sure the united states is in a
complete state of surrender on on the
foreign policy stage and sure we are
facing extraordinary rates of inflation
we are facing people not going back to
work we are facing a completely
innervated american public but this is
all good according to booty judge
part of what's happening isn't just the
supply side it's the demand side demand
is off the charts retail sales are
through the roof and if you think about
those images of
ships for example waiting at anchor on
the west coast
you know every one of those ships
is full of record amounts of goods that
americans are buying because demand is
up because income is up because the
president has successfully guided this
economy out of the teeth of a terrifying
recession okay is that what's going on
right now is that this
commander-in-chief has guided the
economy out of a terrifying recession
because i'm getting the impression that
this commander-in-chief is guiding
america into a recession for no reason
at all considering we put the entire
economy of the united states in an
artificial coma for a year he'll get
some more of this in just one second
because again the promise is get in the
warm bath split those risks and enjoy
yourself as the final days of the
republic play out before you we'll get
to more of this in a second depressing
message but you know we got rid of truth
justice in the american way so it's
better tomorrow we'll just call that a
better tomorrow first if you've got a
small business no there's nothing more
valuable than your time stop lacing it
on trips to the post office stamps.com
makes it easy to mail and ship directly
from your computer save time and money
with stamps.com some letters and
packages for less with discounted rates
from usps ups and more here at dailywire
we've used stamps.com since 2017. we do
not waste our time since 1998 stamps.com
has been an indispensable tool for
nearly one million businesses stamps.com
brings the services of the us postal
service and ups shipping directly to
your computer whether you're in office
sending invoices a side hustle etsy shop
or a full-blown warehouse shipping out
orders stamps.com will make your life
easier all you need is a computer and
standard printer no special supplies or
equipment within minutes you're up and
running printing official us postage for
any letter any package anywhere you want
to send it
and you'll get exclusive discounts on
postage and shipping from usps and ups
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off no traffic no
lines cut the confusion out of shipping
with stamps.com's new rate advisor tool
you can compare shipping rates and
timelines to easily find the best option
save time and money with stamps.com
there's no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page type in shapiro
that is stamps.com promo code
shapirostamps.com never go to the post
office again all right we're gonna get
to more in just a second first if you
missed the sunday special yesterday you
need to check it out it's great i'm
joined by none other than barry weiss
brilliant writer journalist now the
voice of our own excellent podcast it's
called honestly with barry weiss it is
always worth the listen we sat down to
make sense of everything that is going
on today it is truly worth your time we
talk about the destruction of the new
york times from within we talk about the
need for people on the center left to
make common cause with conservatives why
open debate and true classical
liberalism are necessary go check it out
at dailywire.com or on my youtube
channel ben shapiro daily wire members
get access to special bonus content from
the sunday special episodes do not miss
out join daily wire today also there's
no questioning the legacy media's
unparalleled ability to distort the
facts that's why we are using our newest
podcast morningwire to continue our
commitment to bringing you the news
without a hidden agenda it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending toward number one so
subscribe and start listening now to
morningwire on apple spotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile the continued push for
workers not to enter the workforce is is
strong and continuing and it really is
so union leaders are now taking
advantage of the labor shortage in order
to push for quote unquote higher wages
which of course really means lower real
term wages because all of that cost is
going to be passed on to the consumer
according to the wall street journal
union leaders are pressing to increase
their ranks and secure gains for their
members as workers demand more from
their employers and companies struggle
with labor shortages and scenario supply
chains a walkout by production workers
for farm and construction machinery
company deer and company that began on
thursday followed recent stoppages at
snack producer monsley international
commercial truck maker volvo and
breakfast cereal giant kellogg labor
leaders elsewhere this year have worked
to unionize starbucks baristas and
amazon.com warehouse workers so far with
mixed success union officials said
workers are motivated by lingering
frustration over their hours pay and
concerns for their health as some have
held frontline jobs through the covet 19
pandemic employees this year have pushed
for higher wages expanded benefits safer
workplace and added staffing okay now
the the reality is that the militancy of
the unionized workers is being forwarded
by the fact that the government is
paying everybody else to stay home you
don't have to kneecap all of the
prospective workforce when it turns out
that that prospective workforce is happy
to stay home and pick up the child tax
credit
so the the continued
attempt to iv the american public
benefits has consequences and democrats
want to do more of this they want more
of this case they continue to push
forward with this 3.5 trillion dollar
budget plan now they're admitting that
they're not going to get to 3.5 trillion
dollars but joe biden is saying if we
don't get 3.5 trillion dollars now we'll
come back and we'll get back the rest
here is the president of the united
states daughtering his way through
another press conference
i told you before what my
neurosurgeon years ago said when i had
that aneurysm
he said your problem that was in the
senate your problem centers you're a
congenital optimist
but i'm convinced we're gonna get this
done
i'm convinced we're gonna get it done
we're not gonna get 3.5 trillion dollars
we'll get less than that
but we're going to get it and we're
going to come back and get the rest and
we're going to come back and get the
rest so that is biden undermining his
own
his own agenda here right because if he
actually wants to get a deal done he
can't keep like he keeps doing this over
and over but the goal here is the
spending the goal here is to change the
relationship of americans to their
government
remember the reason that they are
currently in a budget impasse is because
joe biden said that he wanted to pair
the infrastructure bill with the budget
bill he said okay we can whittle down
the infrastructure bill but everything
that doesn't go in the infrastructure
but we'll put in the budget bill and
then joe manchin and christian cinema
were like nope we're not gonna do that
now joe biden is saying okay so
we paired down the infrastructure bill
everything that doesn't go in there is
gonna go in the budget bill now we're
gonna pare down the budget bill
everything that doesn't go in there is
gonna go on a third bill
okay if you keep saying this all you're
doing is prolonging a crisis inside your
own party
okay so democrats will come up with some
big spending plan here obviously i can't
imagine that they get all the way to the
end of the year and they have not passed
something they have to pass something
according to the wall street journal
democrats are still tussling over how to
scale back their ambitions to expand the
country's social benefits and overhaul
its climate change policy and they are
facing dwindling time to reach an
agreement as both the house and the
senate returned to washington this week
one major element related to climate
change 150 billion program aimed at
pushing utilities to draw more power
from clean energy sources could be cut
from the bill because senator joe
manchin of course comes from west
virginia which is a call state
he is saying i don't want incentives
that tell people not to use coal and so
what they're probably going to do is
create incentives for individuals to use
alternative sources of power but that he
doesn't want coal plants punished per se
and so they'll probably figure out a
different way of doing that mired in
internal policy disagreements democrats
early this month passed a short-term
extension of highway funding until the
end of october setting up a new deadline
for much of biden's legislative agenda
while passing the democrats marquee
package won't be feasible by months end
the timing has renewed pressure on
democrats to reach a rough consensus
regarding its parameters remember they
only have until the beginning of
december to finish all of this and then
they run up against the debt ceiling
again and this time republicans ain't
going to help them republicans are going
to be able to say listen we helped you
last time we pushed it off for like a
month and a half you still couldn't get
it done it's now on you
the proposed benefits for families with
children including subsidized child care
and extension of an expanded child tax
credit and universal pre-k for three and
four-year-old children are tangled up in
the broader fight within congress in his
remarks on friday biden expressed doubts
about whether the final package would
include all of the funding he wanted for
community colleges
democrats plan to advance the social
policy package through a process that
allows them to skirt gop opposition in
the senate but manchin and cinema are
basically in control over there
asked on sunday
on cnn about joe manchin's objections to
all of the climate change garbage p
buddha judge said the administration
remains committed to climate action
quote exactly what legislative forum
this takes is what's being negotiated
right now but the bottom line is we have
to act on climate for the good of our
children and by the way for the good of
our economy which of course is false
they're not doing any of this for the
good of our economy
so the democrats continue again to push
this radical redefinition of what it
means to be an american
this radical redefinition of the
relationship between you and the
government the new york times openly
says that the bible administration is
pushing cradle to grave government
programming
how much of that are they going to get
the answer is more than they more than
they would if they're republicans in
charge
it's maybe it's incremental for them but
that is certainly the goal and to
disconnect that from the giant culture
where we are currently having over the
future of the united states and whether
the united states ought to even exist as
a country proud of itself ready to fight
for its own values on the world stage
now that
there is a relationship between those
two things
and that relationship is going to define
whether the united states has a future
or whether in fact it does not alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show today he discusses
delta ditching their vaccine mandate you
can hear more details about that story
over on michael's show that's available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
the transportation secretary remains
missing in action on paternity leave
inflation hits a 13-year high and a
major airline ditches its vaccine
mandate check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]